[LAUGHTER]
GET A REBOUND.
NOT ONE PERSON CRASHED THE
BOARDS.
[LAUGHTER]
ALRIGHT.
LET'S RESET THE SHOT CLOCK AND
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THIS KID
DUNKED HIMSELF IN THIS WEEK'S
BREAKDOWN.
♪♪
[APPLAUSE]
YOU NEVER SEE RICH PEOPLE WITH
TRAMPOLINES.
IT'S LIKE AN ABOVE-GROUND POOL.
IT'S JUST NOT AN UPSCALE PIECE
OF LAWN FURNITURE.
[LAUGHTER]
HEY, AT LEAST THEY SPRUNG FOR
THE SAFETY NET.
WHAT COULD GO WRONG?
WELL, HERE'S ONE THING: THESE
KIDS COULD START DOUBLE-BOUNCING
THE [BLEEP] OUT OF EACH OTHER.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
WHAT A DOUBLE BOUNCE IS, IT'S
THE TRAMPOLINE EQUIVALENT OF A
SPEEDBALL.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
WHAT A SPEEDBALL IS, IT'S WHAT
KILLED JOHN BELUSHI.
[LAUGHTER]
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
WHO JOHN BELUSHI IS, HE'S JIM
BELUSHI'S BROTHER.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
WHO JIM IS, HE'S THE GUY FROM
"ACCORDING TO JIM."
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DIDN'T
WATCH "ACCORDING TO JIM,"
CONGRATULATIONS.
[LAUGHTER]
OH, WOW IS HE UP THERE.
SOMEBODY JUST CAUGHT FIRE NBA
JAM STYLE.
[LAUGHTER]
SAVOR THE MOMENT, SCOTTY SKILES,
'CAUSE IT'S ABOUT TO TURN SOUR.
THAT'S A TECHNICAL FOUL.
GET OFF THE RIM.
[LAUGHTER]
YEAH.
SUCK IT, VINCE CARTER.
DANGLING BY YOUR ELBOW, DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE SUCH A BIG DEAL
ANYMORE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HMM.
IT HURTS TO HEAR.
THIS IS WHERE HE AND HIS TORN
ACL COULD LEARN A LESSON FROM
SASCHA.
JUST DISTRIBUTE THE BALL, SET
SOME SCREENS, AND DRAW DEFENDERS
OUT OF THE LANE SO REAL PLAYERS
CAN PUT ON THE SHOW.
[LAUGHTER]
AND WHY IS HE CRYING LIKE NANCY
KERRIGAN?
[LAUGHTER]
YOU'RE WHITE.
YOU DON'T GET TO DUNK.
[LAUGHTER]
AND I HATE TO POINT THIS OUT,
BUT THE BLACK GUY'S RUNNING
AWAY.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
AND WHO CAN BLAME HIM?
NOTHING GOOD HAS EVER COME FROM
A BLACK GUY STANDING OVER A
CRYING WHITE KID.
[LAUGHTER]
AH, AT LEAST THE CAMERA GUY WAS
ABLE TO STOP LAUGHING LONG
ENOUGH TO PUT THIS SPORTSCENTER
HIGHLIGHT AND FOR THAT WE THANK